hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's VR we are gonna move on to
stuff apparently I don't know how true
this is but someone said that if you get
the four keys a fifth key will spawn and
you can use that to open the celery I
don't know how true that is
but if I have time later I will come
back to that but for now I'm gonna try
the new things build a mangle and maybe
get to hallway if I have the balls to do
it
okay push buttons grab and release pull
trigger okay I'm gonna wait building
mangle
I just realized what build the mangle
meant we get to actually build mangle
that's like a thing that all the kids
have been able to do forever since five
nights at Freddy's 2 well goody goody
gumdrops I guess I'll have fun with this
welcome to the fazbear entertainment
fulfillment center alright today we are
assembling animatronic performers each
animatronic unit will bring joy to the
children at one of our many freddy
fazbear locations great just place the
necessary components in the assembly
shoot conveniently located at the front
of your workstation not great each work
order is unique so gather only the
components as shown on the quad monitor
array use the high voltage shock buttons
to gently remove any unwanted critters
that stumble onto the assembly line Oh
let's get to work okay oh okay that's a
slow countdown okay okay um no no shock
you out there I need an arm oh God
hey Wow
I need you no I don't need you I don't
need you would all get out you leg leg
am I supposed to leg oh that was not
right
oh wait no okay this I saw this wait no
wait I saw this before oh that's not
what I meant to do I meant to do yeah
you're already assembled hey ain't you
just a big ol bag of dicks okay cool
hey wait lag okay hi um listen you don't
need to worry about I saw this before
let's put that in there okay what about
this lug yeah definitely that leg okay
what about big bear leg oh yeah you want
the big bear leg in there I know what
you like and I know what you want well
done oh let's see how you did what did I
make Oh looks like there aren't enough
component where why perhaps the
instructions were not clear perhaps you
should seek employment elsewhere perhaps
you should be merciful to me mangle all
right hi you are big all right cool good
great good hi whoa wait are you closer
wait a minute wait are you you seem you
seem closer and also bigger oh you are
you are definitely closer I am dead
something's changed I don't like that
okay let's try that again
skip all right let's do this I'm I mean
I know okay so we need head some kind of
head I don't know what kind of head leg
this leg no this leg I said oh
you good away yes I know this definitely
this definitely okay this big guy
definitely why am I going up get me down
there
sorry I got taller you know how it is I
just always have to keep my height in
check it out there food don't you dare
go in there okay uh-uh big way I shocked
you get in there
okay good arm I saw I thought I saw get
down that damn it uh we can't we can't
definitely be handle okay I need a head
of some kind I need it I need some kind
of a head Oh arm yeah disarmed finger
okay you get in there okay
ah this no no no no your will oh let's
see how you did
did I do good Hey Oh No it looks like
there aren't enough component component
instructions were not clear perhaps you
should seek employment it's perfect
piece of cake but engineering is just
that simple par see you next time hmm
what I did it I did it
that doesn't make a lot of sense of how
I did it but you say I did it
so I you can see I'm a little bit
confused here
oh whoa
all right well that's that was something
I guess I did it this probably does okay
trick or treat I don't know what this
means but I got a bad feeling doorbell
look through windows dancer wear masks
to trigger hold the lean oh good oh good
I'm guessing one's gonna be good in
one's gonna be bad to answer the door
ass so you know not gonna be do good oh
yeah oh oh god I hate it oh why did I
come
I don't know about this one dunk dunk
dunk anybody there
anybody home okay oh oh one one what why
would the door oh it's a oh yeah it's me
hey come on Dom nah oh hey come on did
is me
I've got wait I've got your face maybe
you're not you might not like that like
this is it not guaranteed to be Bonnie
wait why is Bonnie going away oh okay
okay oh maybe chica
maybe cheep-cheep chica chica oh oh
there's funny I hate all this who's
coming to the damn door Balloon Boy
Balloon Boy
I don't know you come I hate that oh hi
I'm going with chica
hi oh who is it who is it
I would like trick tree oh hey I got it
ha ha ha hi did I get Kent did that get
did it get it did I get anything did I
get anything did you get me oh we para
peekaboo who is you oh you look fun like
Freddie fun you're also getting there
[Music]
yes you are you going away Bonnie he's
going that way who's coming to the door
ah hello zipper wound boy Freddy boy big
Fred man ok Oh God hi hello how are you
can I help you can I help you
is it foxy I bet it foxy I think it's
fuzzy hi how are you you don't help me
at all come on hey
[Music]
hi trick or treat
hi this may be candy or not okay oh my
gosh this is stressful it's all kinda
stressful hey Freddie
I feel like a bit of a bowl I forgot you
were there I feel like a bit of a lawyer
peeking in like this but you know how it
is look see you Balloon Boy oh wait why
why why did that happen oh god I got to
pay attention okay Freddie's moving that
way balloon boy just ran behind the door
boy going that way Fred boys there hope
your Foxy's there Freddie's there no
who's that who's that guy
it's cheap might be balloon boy might be
looming boy I think it's blooming boy
right now right wait no shift shift
change no bloom boy back there it's a
poxy again Fox he's gone
I think it's foxy foxy its foxy again
you're not gonna fool me just because I
think it maybe not be twice
take your training oh I have you good to
see you
I did it don't look at me
why are you looking at me look away look
away oh it's all gone alright well we're
gonna forget about that momentary lapse
suit weakness
well more oh I don't know if I should I
don't typically do I look delicious
delectable okay so good now there's just
threadbare okay what does dread bear
gonna do what's tread bear got going on
it grab it and release what am i
releasing am i releasing dread bear
because that doesn't sound good push but
okay I'll grab and release him but if he
asked me to grab in on unsavory
locations I'm not gonna be about that
I'm just saying no well way back to
research and development today we are
using science to pervert the mysteries
of life and reanimate the inanimate ah
to begin it is customary for the creator
to give a melodramatic speech go on I'll
wait we gather here today to bring them
up good job
now let's wake our little experiment I
hate you old jock I would heard the
crank to lower the platform then throw
the switch I was gonna turn this oh
there's a crank here apparently this oh
it is doing something hey Bert you a
funny daddy's Oh get away from me no I
hate this I hate this I hate everything
about this oh I hate it you're way
closer than I thought you excuse me okay
there bud I guess through this wish
heíd ready Oh hide ready I didn't expect
you to actually say hi lacking the
necessary control module Oh mainly the
brain so let's calibrate one yeah let's
the laboratory tools to adjust the
brains final characteristics what use
the blueprints as a guide for matching
the correct colors size and neuro
feedback loop when you are satisfied
carefully place the brain in the
creatures animatronic head cavity uh-huh
oh why wait I didn't see what it was I
didn't know I'm supposed to be
memorizing anything okay okay okay um
who you know I'm not gonna touch you I'm
gonna inject you with some cooling
liquid right in your eyeballs just keep
that right in there and jab this in your
brain oh okay I don't know
can I just slam this it whoa I can't I
brought shouldn't but wise decisions was
never part of my part of my experience
whoa whoa whoa all right that was sudden
and unnecessary oh hey okay where do you
know okay
report glitches before they spread okay
ah so lesson learned
don't be an idiot well combined innit
we're beginning now Oh dramatic speech
here's my melodramatic speech child
wings I will bring you to life and then
you will not kill me good job thank you
all right what do we got here purple it
was alive but holding the necessary
control module oh I get it I get it I
get it let's calibrate one yellow use
the laboratory tools to adjust no not
inspire that to red use the blueprints
paint for matching the correct colors
cyan and neuro feedback loop okay you
are satisfied carefully place the brain
in the futures animage okay orange stop
that give us Jimmy might be good dark
blue in the cerebellum all right that's
pale green right there and then light
pink right there okay so that's good
there so now we need the right neural
feedback loop what does that mean what
am I trying to go for here I don't know
what I need damn it whoa what are these
do okay so that's the target okay got it
I see I see I see I see okay so we need
low we need slower no turn back on
please oh god I'm out of pop oh god I
don't have time for this okay what's my
target faster okay got it nailed it put
those right right okay whatever let's
try it again
doctor get your ass down it I think it
was this
now it looks like what I just had no it
doesn't know okay this is correct
right okay got it am I good to go I'll
good to slam this thing in there what do
these do
9:15 Oh - oh I get it
this shrinks it no this drinks it
okay gonna get you there - two tiny
brain itty bitty bitty this ain't big
brain time is tiny boy where to go
what oh god I don't drop your brain you
stupid okay let's try this again get
into perfect you love it you love it you
know you love it you want it I'm sorry I
did everything right you tiny brain
you're so small bringing that you can't
even recognize what you need okay we're
in there right that that's what it is
let me just double-check okay we're good
this should be it there's no question
you just make sure power doesn't run out
when up okay we're gonna put it up for
that oh wait did that change this no it
did not
okay we're good this should I don't know
what else you did what what else do you
want
well done Oh God okay to introduce the
creature to the kids for focus testing
wait wait wait what wait you're gonna
still shrimp why you have why do you
have children is your quality assurance
team that seems highly irregular
okay whatever we're gonna forget about
that okay hey thanks for watching if you
have one check out more five minutes
pretty stuff links in the description or
as it suggested videos if you haven't
checked out a heist with markiplier yet
go check it out if you haven't seen my
new channel honest honest yet
links in the description I'm gonna go
that's not fair that was very uncool to
the max I hate you plushtrap
I hate you thank you again
subscribe for more Wang doodle the like
button I guess and thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye
[Music]